EU ministers of Agriculture will have a
second debate on a regulation concerning
promotion measures for agricultural
products on the internal market and in
third countries the regulation proposes
to better inform consumers and other
stakeholders on the high quality of food
produced in Europe for strengthening its
competitiveness and develop new markets
ministers will also discuss the
commission's report on the possibility
to introduce mandatory indication of the
country of origin for meat used as an
ingredient the report addresses the
feasibility costs and benefits of
providing such information on food
labels including the legal impact on the
internal market and on international
trade the conclusions of this report
were expected after last year's float on
beef meat which affected several Member
States furthermore ministers will be
briefed by the Commission on a proposal
for a regulation on organic production
and labeling which aims to renew and
simplify the existing legal framework
later on the day fisheries ministers
will take note of the outcome of the
coastal states consultations on mackerel
and will have the opportunity to
exchange views on the subject the
coastal states mackerel arrangement
involving the EU Norway the Faroe
Islands and Iceland allows for a shared
management approach promoting a
sustainable fishing of this stock it has
not been applied since 2010 but
negotiations have been fruitful between
the EU and some other coastal states